Time for a question for you. In this question
I'm asking you, to give a couple of examples, of
how downloading code, mechanism may be used by a library
operating system. I already, explained to you the concept of
this mechanism. The concept of this mechanism is of
course the fact that a library operating system can say
well here there's a piece of code. That I want
you to run on my behalf, and present it to
exokernel, so that it is now part of exokernel. Sort of increasing the code
base of exokernel by the downloaded code
on behalf of that particular guest operating system.
So this question is asking you to give a couple of examples. Of how
you envision a library operating system may
use this core downloading facility, provided by Exokernel.